estaremos junto a Ucrania el tiempo que
haga falta de esta manera se expresó el
ministro de defensa de Estados Unidos
Loy dustin en su visita las oficinas
centrales de la otan en Bruselas ahí
Austin se reunió con funcionarios de 50
países que prestan apoyo militar a
Ucrania espacio que el funcionario
estadounidense aprovechó para reafirmar
el apoyo de su país a kiev y alentar a
las demás naciones a mantener el
suministro armamentístico el tiempo que
sea necesario
Seguiremos proporcionando a Ucrania las
capacidades urgentes que necesita para
afrontar este momento así como lo que
necesita para mantenerse segura a largo
plazo frente a la agresión de Rusia y no
se equivoquen estaremos con Ucrania a
largo plazo también en Bruselas el
secretario general de la otan James
stoltenberg se reunió con el ministro de
defensa ucraniano para confirmar el
futuro suministro de aviones f-16 por
parte miembros de la alianza así como
para afirmar que la contraofensiva
ucraniana ya está en marcha
es un momento crítico para Ucrania
porque acaba de lanzar una
contraofensiva están ganando terreno es
una lucha
Y estos avances se deben a la valentía
la destreza y el coraje de las fuerzas
armadas ucranianas y rendíamos homenaje
y nuestro respeto a lo que hacen cada
día
el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin ha
condicionado las conversaciones de paz a
que el bloque occidental deje de
suministrar armas a Ucrania Aunque el
mandatario también admitió En días
pasados que su ejército tiene problemas
de munición para continuar la guerra